let me be clear labor got it wrong in  the past we've listened we've learned  and we've changed there are five  principles that I want to set out first  of all securing our borders secondly  restoring the principle that you  contribute before you play achieving  integration in our community ending the  undercutting of local workers and  fifthly rebuilding trust by only making  promises we can keep people may look at  that and say aren't you saying in  another way what Nigel Farage you say he  wants to simply divide people and  exploit people's fears there's a huge  difference between us it's a big  diversion FL about recognizes they made  a mistake it hasn't composed a single  thing to stop that error from continuing  you  every single day British seats hello  one day our country exotica red white  and blue it is 482